ever since the Hogwarts Legacy state of
play months ago revealed three
companions from Gryffindor Hufflepuff
and Slytherin Hogwarts Legacy fans have
been anxiously awaiting for them to
finally reveal the Ravenclaw companion
and they recently did just that or did
they I actually think there's a big clue
in the recent gameplay showcase that
reveals this new Ravenclaw is not a
companion alright so first let's get
straight to the news so on Friday
November 18th Hogwarts Legacy tweeted
you will meet many classmates from
Gryffindor Slytherin Hufflepuff and yes
even Ravenclaw the astronomy loving omit
is just one of those classmates and then
like the other companions that we know
about so far Amit received his own
little companion card and it reads as
follows first we get his full name Amit
fakhar who is a Ravenclaw and then it
reads Amit aspires to be a famous
Wizarding historian and already has
extensive plans for his first Memoir
exceptionally bright and well read he
adores stargazing and always seems to
have the most recent top of the line
telescope at hand a mitt will leap at
the chance to help a friend in need but
once in the thick of things often
realizes he might be better off reading
or writing about certain Adventures than
experiencing them now in addition to
that tweet Community manager Chandler
wood also added some additional context
with this tweet here he said excited to
introduce you to just one more of your
classmates Seb Natty poppy Nelly Zenobia
Lucan Amit and more will all play a role
in your journey as you attend Hogwarts
so again back in that state of Play
trailer they revealed three companions
Nats ionai of Gryffindor poppy sweding
of Hufflepuff and Sebastian sallow of
Slytherin now we have since learned even
more about these and basically have it
confirmed that all of them will have
various quests that are completely
optional Sebastian in fact has gotten
entire trailers dedicated just to him
and we know that at least one of those
quests will have the option of us
learning the unforgivable spell crucio
so their significant backstory that goes
along with this character and then
thanks to the Autodesk presentation a
few months ago we also know that natsai
will have her own optional Quest as well
and thus we assume the same for Poppy
and then most of us had been thinking
and expecting there would be an eventual
Ravenclaw companion as well now first of
all what even is a companion I think
most of us had been defining it as a
character who has an extensive backstory
that you will have the option of
pursuing a questline with him again an
entirely optional side quest with
actually multiple quests and then I
think there's a second component to this
here that at least most of us have been
assuming is that at some point in the
game these companions will be able to
fight alongside or assist us in various
quests now maybe it's just that Quest
that we go on for them I think most of
us were thinking it's probably going to
affect other parts of the game as well
maybe they'll be able to go on other
quests with you if we go to the official
Hogwarts Legacy FAQ they still have a
question on there which reads will
players establish friendships in
Hogwarts Legacy and then the answer some
students at Hogwarts will become friends
as players grow these relationships
remember that word relationship these
schoolmates will become companions who
can accompany players on their Journey
expand their abilities and open up as
players learn their stories so I think
this is the big question right here will
omit fit into this category will he be a
character who can accompany us on our
journey expand our abilities and open up
as we learn more of his story now I
mentioned that there is something I
found in the recent gameplay showcase
that I think a lot of people have missed
that could tell us a little bit more
about what Avalanche is doing here so to
find this you need to go to around 33 38
in the official Hogwarts Legacy gameplay
Showcase Video and this is when the
player character is talking to Lucan
Bradley who heads up the crossed wands
dueling club now the moment the
character completes this little Quest
right here we see this pop up above
lucan's head and says Quest complete
Spell combination practice one but then
also check out this in the top right
here challenge unlocked and then
complete side slash relationship Quest
so there's that word relationship so
guys what I think has happened here here
I think Hogwarts Legacy has done away
with the word companion I don't think
they're going to be referring to natsai
Poppy and Sebastian as companions any
longer and I think instead they're going
to refer to these as different
relationships that we form with the
students in Hogwarts Legacy I think that
is further backed up by Chandler's tweet
notice it's not just Seb Natty and Poppy
anymore he is also throwing in Nelly
Zenobia Lucan those three are three
characters that we meet in the gameplay
showcase and then amid this new
Ravenclaw whom we had not met just yet
so upon first hearing about this I think
there was a lot of concern from fans
that maybe this means omit is not going
to be a fully fleshed outside character
like Poppy natsai and Sebastian but
seeing this shot here from the gameplay
Showcase with Lucan and Lucan by the way
of course has never been referred to as
a companion we met him for the first
time in this showcase and we can see
that even Luke in here has a
relationship Quest that has just been
unlocked by the player now who knows
what all this will entail will it just
be crossed wands or will it be other
things and then going back to the FAQ
What would we be able to grow this
relationship with Luke and will we
become one of his best friends will he
become someone who actually accompanies
us on our journey so if you're worrying
about quests with Amit I would not I
think we are definitely going to have
quests that somehow involve him now will
he have as big of a backstory I actually
still feel pretty good about that as
well the one thing that I am not sure
about is that second sentence here kind
of the middle part of the second
sentence in the FAQ these schoolmates
will become companions who can accompany
players on their Journey that I think is
the big question here about admit and to
be fair Hogwarts Legacy has never said
how many companions how many characters
how many relationships side quests they
have never given us this exact
information here nor should they and
while I don't think we're going to need
every single detail on Amit here and
whether or not he has this big huge
backstory like the others I do think it
would be nice to know if they could
confirm whether or not he is one of
these companions who will fall in this
category of being able to accompany us
on our journey now when you think about
out the little bit of backstory we
already have on him that they include in
the card here it almost sounds like that
he is going to play another role maybe
he is going to be the Thinker the one
helping us plan the one behind the
scenes and not the one actually going
out on these different missions with us
so while of course it's gonna come as no
surprise that Sebastian may help you
sneak around the castle at night to find
something in natsai is gonna help you
seek Justice to find out who's harming a
hippogriff a mitt on the other hand
already has a built-in reasoning I mean
it's just in his personality that he is
going to take a more cautious approach
again let's read it one more time here
Amit will leap at the chance to help a
friend in need but once in the thick of
things often realizes he might be better
off reading or writing about certain
Adventures than experiencing them so I
actually think it will be interesting to
watch in the coming weeks will this
language in the FAQ change we have seen
them update this occasionally at times
just a couple of words changing and then
at other times completely new questions
getting added so I am very curious to
see if they will drop that companion
language eventually and use something
else because they have both relationship
and companion all there in that same
answer now there is one more key angle
to consider here regarding the trophies
I am not going to talk about it just yet
this is your spoiler warning I know some
people do not want to know about any of
the trophies at all I consider this a
minor spoiler but if you don't want to
know anything about the trophies now is
your time to click off okay so minor
story spoilers here what I think is very
interesting about the trophy list is
they do not mention companions instead
there are three specific trophies or
achievements for poppy Sweeting Nats
ionai and Sebastian sallow and they all
say complete their relationship line so
this is actually further evidence for me
that I think Hogwarts Legacy is just
completely dropping this companionship
language now you may be asking what
about Amit is Amit on there no he is not
now if you're Ravenclaw and hearing that
on the trophies makes you worry don't
worry because I think there are so many
other trophies here that omit could
definitely be involved with and then in
a game as big as this guy's not every
Quest is going to have its own specific
trophy that's just not going to happen
there's nothing on here about Lucan
there's nothing on here about Zenobia
however there is one for Imelda and the
broom races so I mean we already have a
confirmed relationship Quest because we
saw it in the gameplay Showcase with
Lucan however that one is not in the
trophy list but how do all of you out
there feel about a mitt do you feel he
is a step below the other companions
that we've learned about so far is he
somewhere in between people like Lucan
and natsai or once we play the game are
we going to be able to see that they all
have their own fully fleshed out stories
and sure maybe some end up being more
important than others leave a comment
below to let me know now that bit about
the relationships was certainly not the
only thing revealed in this gameplay
Showcase in fact we had some big time
reveals and I've already made a video
breaking down what I think are the 20
biggest pieces of new information to
come out from that check it out on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon